getting explanations for your
predictions is becoming increasingly
important how can we use Claudia
platform's prediction service to
generate explanations stay tuned to find
out
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to
explore AI explanations which is now
built into cloud EAJA platforms
prediction service allowing you to have
feature attributions for each and every
one of your predictions AI explanations
integrates feature attributions into AI
platform prediction and it helps you
understand your models outputs for
classification and regression tasks
this means AI explanations can tell you
how much each feature in the data
contributed to the predicted result this
is super useful because you can then
verify the model is behaving as you
would expect recognizer bias as it's
happening and get ideas for how you can
improve your training data and model
feature attributions are available for
tabular data as well as image data and
are specific to individual predictions
currently there is the limitation in AI
explorations that it only supports
models trained on tensorflow 1x and if
you're using carrots to specify your
model you will need to convert it into
an estimator using the model to estimate
or utility now let's talk a little bit
about the particulars of feature
attribution and how it works
ai explanations offers two methods
sampled Shapley and integrated gradients
both methods are based on the concept of
Shapley values which is a cooperative
game theory algorithm that assigns
credit to each player in a game for a
particular outcome here each feature is
treated as a player in that game and
proportional credit is assigned to each
of those features for the outcome of a
prediction integrated gradients are best
suited for differentiable models like
neural networks it's especially useful
for
with large feature spaces it computes
the gradients of the output with respect
to the input multiplied element-wise
with the input itself for those who
remember their calculus class this is
essentially a Taylor approximation of
the prediction function at the input bet
you didn't expect to see Taylor
approximation reference today now let's
talk briefly about the other feature
attribution method sampled Shapley it
assigns credit for the outcome of each
feature and also considers different
permutations of those features and is
most suitable for non differentiable
models like ensembles of trees there are
a number of articles and research papers
which dive way deeper into these
explained ability methods which i've
linked to below they're all very
well-written and super interesting to
read so if you like these topics I would
encourage you to dive in and check them
out if you are ready to try out AI
explains for your deployed model head on
over to the guides in the documentation
there's one for tabular data and another
one for image data and best of all
they're presented as collab notebooks so
it's super easy to try it out one final
note before we wrap up last episode we
talked about the what-if tool an open
source tool for understanding your
models predictions AI explains can be
used in concert with the what-if tool to
get an even more in-depth understanding
of your predictions the process for
doing that is also detailed in those
collab note books I mentioned earlier
and I'll be sure to link to it in the
description below thanks for watching
this episode of cloudy adventures and if
you enjoyed it click that like button
and be sure to subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
for now check out AI explanations on
google cloud a a platform to get your
predictions explained
[Music]